it's great to be joined today by
attorney Mike Papantonio co-host of Ring
of Fire
let's talk Papp first about the latest
with this c8 Teflon dupont case and just
sort of to refresh everybody's memory
when some people hear about this case
they say oh this is a case about Teflon
coated nonstick pans those may have
their fair share of concerns but this is
actually about a chemical involved in
the production of that Teflon surface
yeah it's amazing to me the people that
don't understand what c8 is you hear
about Flint Michigan and you hear about
lead in the water and it's that's bad
that's awful but here here you have c8
in drinking water all over the United
States in about eight or ten major major
urban areas they're drinking c8 not
understanding that the very people who
manufacture c8 as early as the as early
as the 80s and the 90s it was clear to
them that c8 causes cancer and as a
matter of fact they even told their
employees who were working around c8
that it'll cause cancer but they didn't
tell the people who were drinking it
what happens is it's it to two ways it
enters the water by way of air deposits
and also by the way of them simply
dumping the the c8 into waterways the
Ohio River is a great example they
dumped a million seven hundred thousand
pounds into the Ohio River over a period
of time it ended up in people's drinking
order and six major drinking facilities
up and down the Ohio River that supplied
water for about 80,000 80,000 people who
were drinking the stuff every day their
children were drinking it but baby
formula but it doesn't seem to matter I
mean it's a remarkable thing it doesn't
seem to matter to DuPont and now finally
the United States and the DOJ never had
any courage to prosecute they still
won't I mean nothing's really changed
under you know under our latest DOJ so
in Europe they are in Europe they're
asking real tough questions in Amsterdam
for example
you have you have the company being
called in for hearings and they're just
really almost as to step away from
serious prosecution I predict so talk to
us so far financially what has been
awarded and how many individual
potential plaintiffs are you now up to
well I mean so far we've only had two
trials of two individuals and the last
one was tried the jury came back with
5.6 million dollars for a man who had
testicular cancer about 20 years ago and
the case was so strong it really didn't
it didn't bother them that the cancer
had resolved because you know there's a
no there's a notion in this business and
that is that the documents drive damages
in other words once the jury sees that a
real ugly culpable company has done some
horrible things they're not really
focused on damages as much as they are
just some type of retribution and that's
what happened here the first case was
the same jury came back a woman that had
17 years ago had had a kidney cancer
part of her kidney was removed and they
came back with about 1.6 million dollars
so so the and there's 4,000 of these
cases we're going to keep trying them
the interesting thing about these
particular cases we can try them for a
very long time because every time we win
we are actually awarded attorneys fees
the the client in other words the client
is awarded that and so it makes it
fairly easy to be able to try the cases
for a whole host of different lawyers
that can come in there and with the
facts that we have they're gonna win
most times what it this case reminds me
of in some ways is what we've now
learned about Exxon and how early they
knew that their activities with fossil
fuels were damaging to the environment
your work on this case has turned up
that as early as February of 1961 DuPont
became aware that at least in rats c8
exposure was linked to enlargement of
the testes
kidneys adrenal glands etc and there's
this chain of very incriminating
documents going all the way back to 61
here the idea that DuPont just had no
clue has really fallen by the wayside
here I mean it's just not believable
yeah and to me that's why I keep coming
back to me it's remarkable that Loretta
Lynch or Eric Holder have done nothing
about this case I mean they're they're
all into what happened in in Flint in
Flint was an awful thing but here these
c 8 c 8 is so ubiquitous now that
they're finding it in polar bear livers
because it stays in the environment for
five million years it stays in the human
body for for 25 years and so it's what
we call bio persistent it's not each and
every exposure you have to the product
builds up in the body and it runs a
higher risk of causing neurological
damage birth defects cancer and the
Department of Justice has done nothing
has done nothing at all to look into
this thing like they're doing over in
Europe because DuPont has such strong
politics in this country and they're
able to back you know they're able to
back they back Eric Holder down and so
I'm sure the same thing is happening
with Loretta Lynch it's I don't know how
we ever hold them responsible
David the problem is you dress them up
in an Armani suit put a gold watch on
and have them driving around in a
Bentley and all of a sudden they don't
look like thugs they don't look like
criminals but they are criminals they're
liminal so I'm sorry Apple of killing
criminals you're capable into far more
damage than anybody
typically ends up in prison you and I
have talked about how on so many issues
there are really important differences
between Democrats and Republicans but
when we talk about the power that some
of these corporations have to really
avoid any significant scrutiny from both
Republican and Democratic
administrations I mean is this one of
those areas where Republicans and
Democrats alike are both part of the
same problem Democrats have been as much
help to DuPont as Republicans
I try to case
one time just show you how how full the
Democrats are behind it we had a case at
horrible environmental case in West
Virginia but the jury ultimately came
back with 380 million dollars against
DuPont but the the Democratic
establishment and in Joe Manchin himself
the governor the at the time was doing
everything they could to cause harm to
the claimants his own constituents in to
prop up DuPont at every turn that that
is the new DuPont that that is the new
centrist Democrat that unfortunately we
see now running with Kane and Hillary
not much is different I mean so these
people that we see we see Democrats do
better on social issues David they do
well on things like gender issues and
rights issues but where it comes to
things like Wall Street where money
affects politics hugely the Democrats
are absolutely absolutely no different
than Republicans and as a matter of fact
I have a book coming out in September
that I talked about this very issue it's
a it's a book called yeah well it'll be
released in in September 20th lon
disorder and I spend some time talking
about the fact that we're kidding
ourselves if we think there's much of a
difference here last thing I want to
touch on when you hear the reaction from
DuPont to everything that's going on
with c8 you will sometimes hear this
talking point that hey we've we've
phased out c8 we're now using and it's
amazing because the name is almost the
same we're now using c6
instead it's because e6 is already
showing the same types of patterns in
research that c8 was isn't it actually
they're showing worse patterns David
because it has the the biological uptake
is quicker with a c6 and again it's the
EPA asleep at the wheel not really sleep
at the wheel they know exactly what
they're letting DuPont do but again
money talks with both Democrats and
Republicans and that's why DuPont has
been able to kill so many people over
the years with their product and so we
have people that died of cancer for
decades and they didn't they never saw
the connection they never
they were drinking this cancer-causing
substance in the water showering with it
swimming in it
eating fish out of the river where the
pollutant is and so family members die
and they have no idea that there's a
connection here before we let you go to
tell us a little more about the book
which as you mentioned is coming out
September 20 if it's currently available
for pre-order on Amazon what can you
tell the audience about there's sort of
like a fictionalized David Pakman in the
story isn't there if there is you'll
like your character in this story David
it's that the point is the point I make
about you and other people in social
media I use your name sometimes I dress
the names up but I used you to make the
point that without people in social
media that do exactly what you do every
day these stories would never be told
corporate media cannot tell the same
story that David Pakman tells because
David Pakman for example is not reliant
on advertisers to keep him alive the big
advertisers like Ford and Merck and
Pfizer so the you so so your role the
role you play in this process is so
critical to getting these stories out
there and that's that's one thing I do
with I hope you like I hope you read it
and you like the character I will
absolutely read it and we will have more
information in the video description
about how to pre-order the book and
we'll have Mike Papantonio back on to
talk more extensively about it we've
been speaking with attorney Mike
Papantonio co-host of Ring of Fire a
great always to talk to you
thank you David III enjoy coming on your
program